- Hi everyone.
Welcome to the daily homeroom livestream.
For those of you all who
are wondering what this is,
this is a series of
conversations that we've started
over the last few months.
It was I guess, catalyzed by COVID.
But it's a way of us staying in contact
and having conversations about education,
what's going on in the broader world.
And I'm super excited for the conversation
we're gonna have in a few minutes
with a guest that when we scheduled it,
we didn't realize how relevant it would be
given what's going on in the world.
But before we jump into that conversation,
I do wanna give a special shout out
to several corporate
partners who stepped up
as soon as they realized that Khan Academy
was already running
into deficit pre-COVID,
and that as our traffic has gone up
by a factor of 2, 2.5, 3X,
we've tried to accelerate more programs
to support teachers, parents and students,
they stepped up to help
us close some of that gap.
Special thanks to Bank of
America, Google.org, AT&T,
Fastly, and Norvatis and
the many other supporters
of Khan Academy.
I just wanna make it very
clear, every donation matters.
We're still running at a deficit.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about making that donation.
So with that said,
I'm eager to introduce
our guest for today,
Mayor Sam Liccardo, mayor of San Jose.
A very large city, a major
city here in Silicon Valley,
the largest city that I'm close to.
I'm here in Mountain View,
which is probably about six or seven miles
away from San Jose.
So I consider myself
a constituent of sorts
of Mayor Liccardo.
Mayor Liccardo thanks so much for joining,
especially considering,
I'm sure a lot of things
going on in your life right now.
- Yes, it's a challenging moment.
But I should say Sal,
thank you for all that you
and Khan Academy are doing
for literally millions
of kids in our country
and throughout the world.
We're so appreciative.
- No, no.
And maybe a good place to start.
As I said, when we scheduled this,
we thought we're gonna talk about COVID
and maybe the economy
and how cities are thinking
about school, education,
but obviously, given what's
going on in the world
around George Floyd and the protests,
and I guess I would just love
your perspective as a mayor
of a major American city,
how are you processing it
as individual and what
levers do you think cities,
or state, or federal government has
to kind of help us navigate this?
- Well, I think as you're saying,
the action really is in the cities.
That is certain that every
police department is local.
We're probably not gonna get
much national leadership on
this given some of the comments
that come out of the White House.
And so, really mayors
are mightily challenged
along with police chief's,
to really see how we
can meaningfully address
the calls for reform that are out there.
There is a righteous cries for change,
and certainly they are
reflective of what is a decades
if not centuries old problem
we have had with race
and equity in this country.
And so, the underlying
challenges are gonna take
a lot more time to solve,
and I think they're fundamentally
racial and economic.
But as we look at this manifestation
that is with the use of
force and police departments
and so forth, this is an
opportunity for a lot of cities,
I think, to step up in ways
to be able to demonstrate
that we are hearing clearly
the cries for change
and to utilize more innovative approaches
that have been used in the past.
I'll give you a quick
example here in San Jose,
and we're by no means perfect.
We are struggling mightily
with this as everyone else is,
but we've been really
trying to leverage data
as much as possible,
recording literally
every single police stop,
every detention, every
arrest, every questioning,
and the demographic
information of each individual.
And then we make that
public and we release it
for outside experts to study.
One of these reports
just came out last week.
They analyze how we're using force
relative to our arrest
rates in each demographic,
and whether or not our use of force
is getting more severe or less severe.
Fortunately, it's becoming less severe.
And really help us
understand how we can change,
how we can improve.
And so, I think being able
to be more transparent
and more accountable is
really a critical first step,
and that's something that most cities
can do relatively quickly.
Obviously, much bigger challenge
is addressing this fundamental challenge
we have around race in our country,
which we could have a very long
conversation about, I know.
- Right, and just focused on
this one issue of use of force,
which is obviously the catalyst
or the center of all this
and obviously there's layers
to that onion as you refer to,
what do you think, I guess how serious,
how prevalent is this in police forces?
What were mayors and Sheriffs
thinking about before this?
'Cause obviously this isn't the first.
It seems like every few
months, there's a case.
Some of them are with the police,
some of them are a case of some vigilante
doing something that to many of us
seem race based, but then it doesn't seem
like justice is served.
What were cities doing
before and how do you think
they should approach change
in both how the
police/citizen interaction,
and then also in the criminal
justice system beyond that?
- Yeah, what's interesting
is I think there have been
a lot of good changes in
recent years in large cities.
Despite the fact what we're
seeing clearly in the media is,
this is still happening way too often
and we know George Floyd,
sadly, won't be the last.
We have seen this happen so often.
And we are desperate hoping
that this will be the last
but we know that there is a
fundamental issue of culture
that needs to change in an
awful lot of departments
in terms of racist attitudes
around use of force.
But I think what is also
particularly challenging
as we see the widespread
demonstrations and protests,
is how you police a large gathering
where 99% of the participants
are peacefully expressing
their first amendment rights.
And yet you know, and this is
true in virtually every city,
'cause I'm having these text exchanges
with all my colleagues and
mayors throughout the country,
very progressive mayors.
None of them want to see
anything but dramatic change.
But they are frustrated
because in each city,
you have provocateurs,
folks who are instigating
and provoking to try to
get a police response.
And maybe it's throwing bottles or debris.
Maybe it's blowing up
fireworks over the heads
of the officers.
Maybe it's looting a whole host of things.
And the officers are really being put
in an incredibly difficult position.
How do you keep everybody safe,
how do you protect the city,
and at the same time,
how do you do it
constitutionally, and fairly?
So very difficult issues
that an awful lot of folks
are grappling with.
I am bullish on the ability
of an awful lot of mayors
and police chiefs to
step up to this challenge
in the long term.
In the short term, I
think this is much harder.
- And those are two
really interesting things
that I would love to double click.
And for anyone watching
on Facebook or YouTube,
please ask questions.
I see some questions coming in already.
I'll get them to the mayor
as much as we have time for
but on the first question,
you say there's some culture,
there are some deep
racism in certain pockets
of various institutions,
including law enforcement.
How do you change culture?
'Cause that feels like something
you can't just change a policy.
I mean, you can do things like body cams
and things like that, so you
can monitor better use of data,
but how do you actually change culture?
What are mayors, sheriffs...
What can the police force themselves do,
what can the community do
to help change that culture?
- Yeah, and that's a really
challenging question,
because it's not just police departments.
Racism, white supremacy,
this is a history that has been with us.
It is in so many institutions,
every institution, really, in our country.
It just so happens when
it's in a police department,
the consequences are deadly.
And so, frankly, we all have
to be a little more honest
with ourselves about this reality.
that it's not just the cop
that deserves scrutiny,
but it's certainly the cop because we know
they're the ones who are
authorized to use deadly force
in our community.
What departments like San Jose are doing
starting three or four
years ago, you ask me
we were one of the first cities
to deploy body worn cameras
and lots of cities are
doing that now and so forth.
But really trying to be intentional
around bias based policing,
we now have training
in every academy and
throughout the career,
every officer here, around
bias and hidden bias,
around the deescalation of violence,
around what we call
critical incident training,
which is really focused on folks
having mental health episodes,
because we know way too
many of those encounters
are resulting in deadly force,
and trying to ensure we can de-escalate
and get mental health
professionals in there,
so that it's not somebody
with a badge and a gun
who's having that first encounter
of somebody having a
mental health episode.
And by the way, those
are in way too frequently
in communities of color,
because of lack of access
to mental health resources.
So there's a lot that needs to be done.
Those are just three training modules
that we've incorporated now
for every single officer
in the academy and thereafter.
And it has to be a focus
on continuous improvement.
Because I like to believe we
are one of the most progressive
departments if not the
most in the country,
and we've got our own failures.
And so there has to be an
attitude around focus of,
we're not perfect,
and we just got to keep pushing.
- And what levers are there?
I mean, those all sound
like very powerful ones.
I think one of the things
that was disturbing
about the George Floyd incident,
tragedy was that not only
did you have the one officer,
kneeling on him,
but then you have several other officers
who kind of stand by and watch
and kind of allow it to happen.
How does that culture evolve
over time so that it's not,
even the more neutral
or the police officers
who wouldn't have done those
types of things on their own,
but they either don't
feel, don't see the space
to confront their peer,
or maybe they're afraid
to for some reason.
I know these are very hard questions,
but how do you get to the
root of that type of culture?
- Those are really important questions,
but we expect police departments
to be paramilitary
organizations that will follow
a chain of authority.
Because when you put
people into situations
where they're under the risk
of serious harm or death
as officers are way too
often in our community
we all live in a violent country,
and this is what officers
are subjected to.
That means they have to follow orders.
And follow that chain of command.
At the same time,
we expect and should expect them
to step out of that chain
and correct one another,
admonish one another, and say,
Hey get off when it appears that somebody
is choking to death.
Those may be conflicting tensions,
and I can't say I'm an expert in policing,
but I think we have to be honest
about our expectations of the police,
at the same time that we're
certainly demanding more
from them and expecting
greater consequence as well.
- And to your second point,
I mean, I completely I could imagine,
many police officers and sheriffs
are really struggling with,
where is that line?
How do you stop looters but
allow for the peaceful protests?
What about the in between situations
where people aren't looting
or doing something illegal,
but maybe they are very
actively antagonizing
hoping for a reaction?
What are those conversations
like with your Sheriff
with the police force right now?
How are they processing it?
I guess on both fronts,
how are they internalizing
some of the change
that needs to happen and
then how are they trying
to thread that needle of
protecting the protests
and also protecting property
and keeping people safe?
- It is challenging and our
police chief here in San Jose
we're city a little more
than a million people,
the 10th largest in the country
and so we have big city
challenges and tensions
and we're very diverse.
And our police chief Eddie Garcia
came to our city as a
child not speaking English.
So he has a certain grasp certainly of,
the intensity of feeling and concern
that's coming from many
corners of our community.
At the same time,
I can tell you he is being
absolutely harshly criticized
because we've got officers out
there encountering protesters
who are protesting abuse of
use of force by the police,
at the same time,
that we are resorting to tear gas,
and yes rubber bullets.
And I have my own very serious concern
about the use of rubber bullets,
for example in crowd management.
But that is used widely in
virtually every big city
in this country.
And so these are really
hard conversations,
they take time,
and they take an ability to reflect
and an ability for folks to take a breath.
And unfortunately,
that's not this moment.
Right now we've got a
lot of folks reacting,
and it's hard to have meaningful
conversations about change,
at the same time that folks are reacting
to the minute to minute stress.
- Right, now there's some
questions about that from YouTube.
Aditya Gupta, just wrote a
question about how do you have
change to your point?
You know, right now there's,
we're in a highly heightened
state emotional state.
People are angry,
often it's kind of like
they've been seeing patterns
over multiple years now.
And there's also a
sense that for everyone,
you see how many hundreds might happen
that you don't see that don't get
happen to get captured on a phone camera?
And then for every one of those,
how many of those don't end up deadly
but could still end up,
quite humiliating or dehumanizing.
And so Aditya asks,
"hi Mayor Liccardo,
what do you think is the
best way to voice change
in our country?
Is it protesting, petitions,
I don't want violence but I
do want effective change."
I think Aditya is kind of voicing
what frankly almost every
American is thinking right now.
- Well, hate to trade on familiar ground
and sound a little too pollyannish.
But get out there and register to vote
and get other people to register to vote.
And, get folks to register for the census
and get engaged in the hard change.
I think, look there's no question that
the demands for change are righteous
coming from protesters in this city
and throughout the country.
At the same time, the
expectations that we're going
to suddenly move and change
major institutions overnight
has never been the reality.
It takes hard work in a democracy.
And it means people have to get engaged
through the ballot box
engaged in the city councils,
engaged in getting people who
are good to go run for office,
who have the values that
are consistent with theirs.
I hate to get too partisan here.
But we do have a real challenge
in national leadership
in this country at this moment.
And we can all imagine
how this conversation
might go differently, if
we had the prior president
rather than this one.
There's only one way
we're gonna change that.
And that means we gotta get
a lot of people registered,
because it's by no means
a forsaken conclusion
what this election is gonna be.
- And what's your sense
of protests themselves?
When you just think about
it intellectually like,
Okay well, it shows solidarity,
it shows a lot of people care about this.
But what do you think is
going to be the impact
of the protests themselves?
Maybe it does activate
more people to vote.
But does it have an impact?
You know, you're in City Hall,
you're talking to a lot of the player?
Does it change thinking in your mind?
- Yeah, I think it does.
There's no question that it's opening eyes
in my conversations with my colleagues
mayors throughout the country
and my own police chief
and others that I think
people are understanding
the depth of the pain in ways
that perhaps we didn't before.
But let me also be blatantly
political for a moment
and coldly calculating,
I am very concerned about
how this narrative plays out.
In perhaps those suburban communities
that may not be as sympathetic.
Where there those on one side essentially
use this to demonstrate
why we need more harsh,
militaristic approach to law
enforcement in this country,
to contain the looting and the violence
and all the other ramifications
of having those folks
who are out there provoking
that kind of response
within the crowds.
Obviously more than 99% of folks
are there for the right reason.
It's those 50 or 100
folks that are creating
the huge challenge in every city
and I'm very concerned about
the long term implications
of what this means for
those suburban voters,
particularly as we go in
this next national election.
- Yeah, it's a complex issue for sure.
And, maybe we'll go one layer out,
because when we first
scheduled this conversation,
obviously we didn't know
that this was going to be
the state of affairs in the world.
And I think, COVID is the underlying thing
and one of the aspects of COVID is,
its kind of heightened a
lot of economic inequality.
And to your point,
a lot of what we're talking about,
even with the protests and
all of that surrounding it,
there is an underlying,
there's a race aspect,
and then mingled with
that is there's kind of
an economic aspect of it.
How do you think,
I guess how do mayors like yourself,
think about this issue?
How do y'all, what levers
are there at your disposal
for addressing economic inequality,
or even educational inequality
or maybe issues like racism generally?
- Yeah, there's no question
at the root of this.
We are seeing the issue played out
around use of force and police,
but at the root of this
issues of racial equity
and economics and the fact
that poverty in this country
is too closely correlated to race.
And I believe that is the root of much
of what we're grappling with.
And we saw that laid bare,
as you said, by COVID,
and we saw the disparities
even more impactful
in terms of health outcomes,
a latin next populations,
Afro American populations
that are dying at higher rates
being affected higher rates.
I'm trying to see how we can use
not use but find
opportunity in this crisis,
and by the crisis now I'm
just referring to pandemic
for a moment.
You know as we think about the ability
to use emergency orders to
move more quickly to mobilize,
for example, we've got a huge
homelessness challenge here
as every city does in California
and throughout the West Coast.
And so we're using some
of the emergency orders
to be able to streamline construction
of prefabricated modular
housing at a relatively low cost
maybe $30-40,000 per unit
where it normally costs
$700,000 to build the unit in
a typical apartment building,
and we'll be able to build
some of these projects now
that we've gotten underway in four weeks
it ordinarily take four years.
You get about 500 homeless
people housed this way.
This is how we can find
opportunity in this crisis
as we think about the digital
divide that is so impactful,
particularly when all the important work
that Khan Academy's is doing right now.
Again, using the ability to
push red tape out of the way
to be able to more
rapidly deploy free WiFi
right now we've got a lot of
interesting projects going on.
Very large school district,
our east part of our city where we have
very high population of
families without internet access
right here in the heart
of Silicon Valley sadly.
And we just connected one community
around James Lick High School
6,000 families with free WiFi.
In a few weeks we'll be able to do that
with another community
around another high school
in eastern Jose.
And we're now gonna do
with three or four more
in partnership with that school district,
we're finding the resources
using a little bit
of the federal money that's been released,
and most importantly,
getting the red tape out of
the way and moving much faster.
So I'm hoping to be able
to leverage this moment
to be able to move more rapidly,
because we know for example,
every child is now learning
online with Khan Academy,
because they have connectivity.
Also has a parent who is
able to find a job online,
and has a grandparent who is
able to get health information.
So we know this is critical.
These are the kinds of disparities
we have to attack aggressively.
- And how do you think,
is COVID, I think in some dimensions,
it's obviously going to make things worse.
It's disproportionately folks
who work in service industries,
things like that.
How are you, I guess in the short term,
I know you have this committee,
that I've been participating in
and many other leaders in the area around.
How do you think we do this,
with restaurants struggling,
and obviously that has
following consequences
with all of the people who work
and supply the restaurants.
How should the city think
about getting through COVID?
And then I guess beyond?
- Yeah in this recovery round table
that we created here in Silicon Valley,
and thanks Sal for being a part of this.
We're really focusing on
how we can most importantly,
get a lot of folks back to work,
who may not be getting
back to work otherwise,
for a year or two based on for example,
if they're in the hotel industry,
it's gonna be a long time
before that industry comes back.
And so we know there's a
lot of low wage workers
there who critically need skills,
Khan Academy can help
as we know they are now
and we want to use whatever
tools we can to help folks
get rescaled and back working again.
And part of this again,
will be around finding
the opportunity in crisis
as we think about the many businesses
that can't do business the same way
because of social distancing.
They've got a small business
and they can't get customers
in and out the door at
nearly fast enough rate.
We announced an Alfresco
initiative to see how
we can get commerce to happen outside
in a city with 300 days of sun a year.
So certainly more outside
seating with restaurants
by getting yoga studios outside
and getting retail outside in a way,
filling up sidewalks and
closing lanes of streets,
to be able to move our activity outside
in a way that may actually be lasting
and maybe something
that's welcoming to folks
who increasingly are thinking
about cities in different ways
and that maybe we really want a city
that is more pedestrian oriented
and less dominated by the automobile.
- I love that last point.
And I do hope it's more permanent.
And actually I think even schools outside
is something that I've
always talked about,
especially out here in California,
you mentioned 300 days,
and I think even getting wet a little bit
on the cold and rainy days
does something for your character.
So I think there's something to that.
Although I haven't heard people talk about
schools outside yet,
but I'll just say I think
that'll be great for the kids,
even if we weren't trying
to socially distance.
So more questions here.
This is, it's going back to
the topic where we started,
but I think it's an
interesting one from Facebook.
Carol Smith Capper asks,
"just wondering how
you identify candidates
for the police department to keep racists
and people who wanna join
for the sense of power
it gives them.
Is there psychological
testing that is done?
What about as they
progress in their careers?"
And I'll just add a little
bit to her question,
which is, and obviously,
this was in Minneapolis not San Jose,
and I know you're not the police chief,
but this was a situation where there was
multiple complaints against
this officer over the years
and so why did not other officers there,
is it that same cultural problems?
Yeah I'd love anything you know about
to answer Carol's question.
- Yeah, great question.
So as you can imagine,
super hard to discern who's
a racist and who's not
when you're signing up for any job.
And there is psychological testing
that's done in our department as I expect
in most other big city departments
as part of the screening,
when folks are going through the process,
and it's a very long process,
I can tell you typically,
we have 14, 1500 people apply
to be part of the police academy,
and about 35 or 40 actually
get into the Academy.
So we're talking about a
very low acceptance rate.
And there's a lot of screening.
Now that being said,
I think the best thing
police departments can do
since we're not as human
beings able to discern,
Malcolm Gladwell actually
just wrote a book
about this recently.
We're not very good at discerning
what strangers really think,
what they're not telling us.
So it's really about having
a really effective system
for identifying the yellow and red flags.
What is the conduct that's problematic?
Both with complaints and
what people are seeing
within the department so that
the internal affairs officers
are really clearly attuned
to who is a challenge,
who needs some training?
Who needs some really clear direction
and who needs to get out quick.
And what is real challenge I think,
in big cities throughout the country
and certainly in
California as we have this
very sclerotic system for
actually meeting out discipline
and firing officers because let's face it,
police unions are very
powerful in every city
in every big state.
And in California we have what's called
police officers Bill of Rights.
We have contracts that
are signed in each city
that make it very difficult
to immediately take action.
We had an incident very recently,
an officer who was involved
in the demonstrations
who was engaged in behavior
that was clearly improper.
And folks are calling on me to fire him,
and I literally have no
authority to fire the officer.
Now I'm not saying that's
what is deserved in this case,
I think we need to understand
and investigate what happened.
Clearly discipline is required.
But I don't have any authority.
And in fact even the police
chief can't move at that pace
because of the way it is
restricted by the contract
and by state law.
So to get better accountability,
we need some real changes
in those legal structures.
And again doesn't happen overnight.
But it's gotta start happening now.
- You know the sense that,
especially with recent incidents,
that might change because obviously,
the union is there to represent
the interests of its members
and obviously these types
of things that happen.
The people who are at the
receiving end of the brutality,
they suffer but also,
other good police officers
suffer incredibly,
their job becomes that much harder.
They get exposed to more anger,
people will trust them less.
Do you sense that pressure
from within the police force
and within the unions to say hey look,
we've gotta take out these actors so that
all of our jobs are going to be better.
- I could say nobody hates a
bad cop more than a good cop.
And I think I really believe
that based on my conversations,
I used to be a criminal prosecutor
I prosecuted sexual assault crimes,
had great relationships
with a lot officers.
And I can tell you,
they despise hearing this
stuff and seeing this stuff.
That being said, I think there are very,
I'll use the word again
sclerotic political structures
in place that need change.
And I had this conversation
with the governor
and a lot of mayors
just a couple days ago,
and there is a lot of pent up interest
among mayors to see this change.
It's gonna take a lot of pushing.
And again, this is why I
say people need to register.
They need to get engaged
and roll up their sleeves,
'cause this stuff isn't
simple and it doesn't happen.
You don't get simple solutions
with tough problems like this.
It takes a lot of pushing
- Well that's super
helpful and Mayor Liccardo,
thanks so much I know
given the circumstances,
thanks for even continuing to take this.
I could imagine your life
as you were telling me
right before, I don't
think you've slept much
the last couple of days.
So I really appreciate taking the time out
for myself and this community
for us to learn about this.
If you have any other
kind of parting words,
happy to share them.
- Well, thanks Sal.
Thank you for the great work
that you and your partners do.
And I think we're understanding certainly
as a result of COVID
the role of Khan Academy
and distance learning is so
critically vital right now.
And we know this is
going to be the future.
So thank you for what you're doing.
Please continue to support Khan
Academy if you're out there.
And we look forward to work together
to see how we can really
solve an awful lot
of our serious challenges
around equity and race
and injustice in our
community through education.
- Well thanks once again for joining.
I learned a lot,
And I think there's some
nuance in what you said
that we're not hearing in
the broader media right now.
So thank you so much Mayor Liccardo.
- Sal always a pleasure.
- So thanks everyone for joining.
Hopefully you found that
as interesting as I did,
this is one of those situations where
I am not an expert in any of this.
But at Khan Academy,
we try to pride ourselves
in being curious.
And this is going to be a learning process
for all of us of how do we
process all of this information?
What are the steps that
we can collectively take,
put one foot in front of the other
so that we can hopefully
move society forward.
So thanks everyone, for joining
and we will continue tomorrow.
Tomorrow will just be your
standard ask me anything.
And then I look forward
to having more guests
like Mayor Liccardo in the weeks to come.
Thanks everyone for joining.